it has been long enough and even though  we absolutely love linus tech tips we  love anthony's coverage we have to say  something because linus tech tips is  wrong about the m1 max macbook pros  there are a couple things that seem just  to be cherry the first one here is  handbrake showing off compressing and  encoding 1080p file why are the m1 pro  macbooks taking way longer to encode  this file than even the m1 mac clearly  there is something very wrong with this  they add 3d rendering using redshift and  show off how it gets smoked by this 3060  system i don't want to just  show off numbers that we have what about  another pc guy like matthew moniz take a  look at blender and how it's  outperforming the previous best cpu  alder lake is beating it out but it's  still super impressive nothing like a  3050 ti and then of course linus tech  devs they didn't mention anything about  unplugged performance which it goes down  dramatically